and then Commissioner seems fun please
go ahead tear up the floor thank you and
good afternoon to everyone it's it is a
pleasure to be back in front of you it
feels familiar I have stood in the same
podium before during the Estonian
presidents and now I'm here for the
first time as the Commissioner for
energy Europe is entering an interesting
but also a challenging period the
discussions taking place now and in the
coming weeks that's a cop 25 in Madrid
in the new European Commission and by
the leaders of the Member States will
determine how our union will move
forward with its ambitious climate
agenda agenda I am happy that I had the
chance to meet and communicate with the
minister's at length so early in my
mandate I should know it is only my
third day in office and I must say that
I'm pleased with the discussions we had
today next week this commission will lay
out its plans for a European clean deal
it's a tai chi that makes europe cleaner
and cleaner while also improving the
that is silence and competitiveness of
our economy from my perspective I see my
priorities under three pillars that will
carry the weight of the energy
transition and these are people the
planet and the partners the first pillar
is the people I will not be able to
achieve our goal of climate neutral
Europe unless we can show the tangible
benefits that this great for our
consumers everyone should be able to
benefit from affordable secure and clean
energy to achieve this I will work
towards open integrated and falen
functioning energy markets I will
address energy poverty and focus on
energy efficiency not just in buildings
but across all policy areas I will
cooperate with industries to help them
lead in clean energy technologies and
support European industrial competitive
the Commission is committed to promote
the climate transition that is just and
leaves no one behind that's why I'm
working closely with executive vice
president France Timmerman's and
commissioner ELISA Ferreira
to propose a chest transition mechanism
that will support people and creations
in an effective and targeted way the
second pillar will be the cut emissions
further and foster the energy sectors
contribution to the health of power
plant
either let attend the cop 25 meeting in
Madrid next week to add my voice to
those of my colleagues in encouraging
the rest of the world to address climate
challenges as seriously as the US and in
the energy sector in particular the
president has announced that the
Commission represent next year a
comprehensive plan to reduce emissions
by 55 percent in a reasonable way by
2030 and energy will play a key role in
this in particular through more energy
efficiency and renewable energy among
other avenues I will examine ways to
strengthen the contribution of offshore
wind energy and push for further
cost-effective decarbonization by
looking at synergies across the
different sectors and we're clean Casas
biogas and hydrogen and make an
important contribution today's debate on
smart sector integration will also feed
into this work the third pillar is our
partners there is no better test case
for our ambition to be a geopolitical
commission than the energy field the you
account for only 9 percent of the global
emissions if we do not bring our
strategic partners with us our isolated
efforts will be in vain
moreover and it is one of the most
traded commodities for the you thus
we should step up to the way we conduct
our external energy relations
I intend to develop a cleaner agenda for
the best importance and place a greater
emphasis on cooperation with Africa in
particular our south and neighborhood
achieving the vicious targets is
impossible without proper tools national
energy and climate plans allow us to map
the way forward our 2030 targets all
together today was a good opportunity
for me to discuss and remind the
ministers of the need to deliver
ambitious national energy and climate
plants by the end of this year and I
want to thank all of those countries who
have already increased their ambitions
it will be my priority to work closely
with others to provide all possible
support by the Commission to close the
tax in addition to this I had the
opportunity to inform the council about
the external dimensions of energy budget
policy at the state of play of the
trilateral gas talks finally I would
like to use this moment and also would
like to thank our Finnish friends and
the minister for stepping in you did a
great job and I know that all your also
your colleagues and the Minister and
Minister of Energy say she was very
dedicated I hope that you will have new
government before the end of the
presidency but please give my best
regards to country and and thank you for
great job and I'm looking forward to
working with incoming president
separation presidents who have high
expectations for their presidency for
next six months in 2020
so it has been a fruitful day good
discussions and I'm very thankful for
those this opportunity on my third day
in office thank you thank you